we cannot grow our economy or reduce the
heavy burden of national debt without
first cutting High persistent inflation
inflation makes every person in this
country poorer
it is the most Insidious tax rise there
is
and that is why the Prime Minister has
made it this government's priority to
harvest this year
inflation is currently at 8.7 percent in
May and core inflation stood at 7.1
percent in the 12 months to May 2023 the
highest for 30 years
it's making everything from groceries
and clothes to petrol and transport more
expensive
so we must
and we will
do everything we can to tackle inflation
the best tax cut there is is a cut to
inflation
and that means we must take responsible
decisions on the public finances
including public sector pay
because more borrowing is itself
inflationary
according to recent IMF estimates
advanced economies which increased
public expenditure by one percentage
point
which would mean 25 billion for the UK
saw inflation Rise by half a percentage
point
yet our decision is responsible because
unlike some unsustainable demands we
have delivered awards that don't further
fuel inflation and make the inflationary
environment worse
Madam Deputy speaker we said we would
accept the outcome of the public pay
review bodies and that is exactly what
we will do and we will do so because we
are proud of our world-class public
servants and owe them a debt of
gratitude for their service through the
last few years including through the
pandemic
our police officers work tirelessly to
keep this country safe our Armed Forces
defend us our doctors and nurses make
sacrifices to save lives
our teachers go to school day in day out
to educate our children all of them and
many more across many sectors play a
vital role in society
with these contributions in mind
new teachers will start on at least
thirty thousand pounds the lowest paid
Armed Forces will see a pay rise of over
two thousand pounds and the starting
salary of a junior doctor Will Rise by
more than three thousand pounds
and that comes alongside our agenda for
change deal which delivered a five
percent pay rise along with one-off
Awards worth more than 3 600 pounds for
the average nurse and More Than 3 700
pounds for the average ambulance worker
specifically that means policing will
receive a seven percent headline uplift
NHS Consultants SAS doctors salary
dentists and salary GPS will receive
uplifts of six percent this year
Junior doctors will also receive a six
percent uplift as well as an additional
Consolidated 1250 pounds increase
prison officers in the operational bands
will receive a pay increase of seven
percent with larger increases for
support grades
Armed Forces will receive a five percent
uplift with an additional Consolidated
one thousand pound increase
our 6.5 pay award for teachers will be
fully funded with the government
providing 525 million of additional
funding for schools in 2324 and a
further 900 million in 24 25.
in order to achieve this we are
re-prioritizing within the department of
education's existing budget to deliver
this additional funding to schools while
protecting Frontline services
but alongside generous uplifts today's
deal strikes a balance it is a fair deal
which recognizes the anxiety caused by
cost of living pressures
supports Recruitment and Retention and
delivers one of the highest settlements
in three decades
but it is also fiscally responsible
and delivers pay Rises that are broadly
in line with the private sector
it will be neither Fair nor affordable
to meet unsustainable demands for pay
Rises well into double digits
to do so would be fiscally irresponsible
increasing national debt passing the
buck to Future Generations weakening the
foundations of our economy and further
fueling inflation
so there will be no new borrowing or
spending to fund the awards
because more borrowing would simply add
more pressure on inflation at exactly
the wrong time
risking higher interest rates and higher
mortgage rates
instead the awards will be funded
through a combination of the significant
provision for pay that was made at the
last spending review greater efficiency
and reprioritization
departments will be re-prioritizing
within existing budgets and driving
further efficiencies to focus spending
where it delivers the greatest value
we will also take make take sound
choices to maximize income
we plan to increase the rates of the
immigration Health surcharge which have
been frozen for the last three years
despite High inflation and wider
pressures facing the economy
and the system in general to ensure that
it covers the full health care costs of
those who actually pay it under our
plans the main rate will increase to
1035 pounds and the discounted rate for
students in under 18s will increase to
776 pounds
this increase to the surcharge will help
fund the pay rise for doctors
at the same time we will increase fees
across a range of immigration and
nationality routes including for people
coming here to live work and study at a
time of record high migration numbers
specifically this means increasing the
cost of work visas and visit visas by 15
and increasing the cost of study visas
certificates of sponsorships settlement
citizenship wider entry clearance and
leave to remain visas and priority visas
by at least 20 percent
we're also equalizing costs for students
and for those using a priority service
so people pay the same whether they
apply from within the UK or from outside
the UK
and this will help cover more of the
cost of the migration and Border system
allowing the Home Secretary to divert
more funding to police forces to help
fund the pay rise for the police
on civil service recruitment in the
ministry of Defense until March 2025
helping fund the pay rise for armed
forces
the government's carefully calibrated
approach
to avoid increasing inflation
could not be different or further away
from the economic platform offered by
the party opposite
Labor's proposals for an unfunded 28
billion bands a year spending spree in
the second half of the next Parliament
would deal a huge blow to our Collective
efforts as a country to tackle inflation
and you'd have to take my word for it
Madam Deputy speaker we already have the
view of the independent Institute for
fiscal studies it's director Paul
Johnson said just a few weeks ago that
additional borrowing would pump more
money into the economy potentially
increasing inflation and driving up
interest rates
so Madam Deputy speaker the action we
have taken today is the most responsible
Way Forward
striking a balance between the demands
of our public sector workers
and the needs of our country and economy
industrial action has postponed more
than six hundred thousand Hospital
appointments cost our children more than
a million days of teaching and damage
the productivity and growth that we so
clearly need in these challenging times
we have introduced an expanded this with
the strikes bill which will limit the
impacts of industrial action on the
lives and livelihoods of ordinary people
who should be able to access key
Services during industrial action
the bill gives us the power to set
minimum service levels across the key
Public Services Health Care fire and
rescue public transport and education it
gives us the right tools to deal with
any ongoing disputes
so Madam Deputy speaker we must deliver
on the prime minister's pledge to cut
inflation
so we will continue to chart the course
of sound money to the benefit of all
whilst making Fair pay Awards awards
that do not fuel inflation to our public
sector workers
actually Pat McFadden
thank you madam Deputy speaker and can I
begin by thanking the chief secretary
for the advanced copy of his statement
today I want to begin by praising
the efforts of our NHS staff teachers
police officers and members of the Armed
Forces
the nurse who looks after someone when
they're ill
the teacher who opens up New Horizons
for a pupil
the soldiers the police officers who
keep us safe we owe them all a great
debt of gratitude they are what makes
the good society and we all rely on the
public services that they provide every
day
unlike all workers they deserve a decent
pay rise unlike all workers they are
living in a wider economic context now
the government set out a plan at the
start of the year
and then the economy
intervened on their plan
they say that a plan doesn't survive
contact with the Enemy
with this government's plan it hasn't
even survived contact with reality
just a couple of hours before the chief
secretary gave us his statement today
we had news that the UK economy shrank
in size last month
and even more worrying
this comes after four years in which
there has been no meaningful economic
growth at all
today's obr fiscal risk report
describes what it calls a disappointing
decade for economic growth and that
disappointing decade means that in
reality incomes for households including
the workers that we're speaking about
today have stagnated and sometimes
fallen and the country is less
prosperous and more exposed to shocks
than it should be that's the backdrop to
today's statement now ministers want to
claim that all these problems are global
but inflation in the UK is the highest
in the G7 and every month when the
figures come out they're higher than
expected core inflation was actually up
last month not down food prices are
rising 20 faster in the UK than France
and three times faster than in the
United States
low growth high prices creaking public
services that is the Legacy we now have
after 13 years of the conservatives in
power longer waiting times and waiting
lists and over 3 million days lost to
Industrial action this year alone now
the chief secretary in his statement
topped of sound money
but the government's failings on public
services have become economic failings
too let me just give the house one
example as the ubr pointed out in their
risk report today if we got labor force
participation back to pre-covered Levels
by reducing ill health we could reduce
borrowing by 18 billion pounds so the
long waiting list and the long waiting
times are not just a health issue they
are an economic issue too and after the
conservative party put a bomb under
mortgage rates last Autumn UK homeowners
are now paying 2 000 pounds a year more
than in France 1200 a year more than in
Belgium and 800 a year more than in
Germany it's not all global
now the chief secretary drew a contrast
with this party well let me tell him the
labor record on public services which
are at the heart of this statement was
investment and reform in the NHS shorter
waiting times and waiting lists the
highest levels of public satisfaction
with the NHS since its foundation in
1948 and a fraction of the days lost to
Industrial disputes that we have seen
under this government we also had better
economic growth so when it comes to
sound money I should remind him that if
he'd continued with the labor rate of
economic growth the treasury would be
tens of billions of pounds a year better
off than it is today so let me ask him
what is the government's estimate of the
impact on public services of funding the
rises in the way that he's set out the
chief secretary talked of
re-prioritizing does that mean the
government will cut back on capital
investment in schools and hospitals to
fund these increases
what is the estimated impact of the
Civil Service recruitment freeze that
he's announced for the ministry of
defense today
of what would be the impact on the NHS
recovery program which has been set out
will it mean what will it mean for the
shocking level of waiting lists and
waiting times that we see under this
government he said
there would be no new money but he also
said that the rise for teachers was
fully funded with new money which is it
and can he clarify the two things that
he said in his statement about that
so Madame Deputy speaker the economic
backdrop that we have colors everything
in this statement it's no longer a
matter of judging if the conservative
government will feel the fact is they
have already failed and that's why the
general election cannot come soon enough
Chief secretary well thank you madam
Deputy speaker it's not really clear to
me or I think the house as a whole
whether they're an honorable gentleman
accepts the government's uh acceptance
of the pay-review bodies in full today
or not he seemed to have written his
speech with a general critique of the
government's economic policy without
actually addressing what matters most to
public sector workers up and down the
country that we have listened carefully
to the evidence-based advice as is
typical over the last 30 years and
agreed with all of those recommendations
and he paints a plan he paints a picture
of the last Labor government and
projects forward as if it was Utopia and
that's why of course they they didn't
win the 2010 general election and while
one of my predecessors said that there
was no money left if you didn't take
those difficult decisions Madame Deputy
speaker between 2008 and 2010 then of
course that was a situation when he was
attending cabinet I believe that we were
in
he does make some other observations
about the economy I I'm aware obviously
of the record growth over the last two
years I acknowledge the challenges we
face at this point in time and I've set
them out in full with respect to
inflation
but we have gone through a pandemic
where we borrowed significant sums of
money when we came out of that pandemic
we find ourselves in the first war in
Europe for several generations and that
is the context I think the people of
this country understand
I've said I've set out very clearly all
the implications for each Workforce and
there'll obviously be a series of
written ministerial statements for from
each government Department
um he also sets out some questions about
waiting lists I I recognize the
challenges faced in the NHS and that's
why it's one of the prime minister's top
priorities we've made real progress with
the virtual elimination of the two-year
weights not 18 month weights down 90
percent but I acknowledge there's more
work to be done the 2.4 billion invested
in the workforce plan will make a
considerable contribution to that and of
course Madam Deputy speaker the
productivity review that the chancellor
tasked me with leading a few weeks ago
will look further at how we can drive
more efficiencies in the way that we
spend uh public money but I want to
finish my initial response if I may by
just reiterating to the house this
afternoon that the decisions we have
made today mean no new borrowing no cuts
to the front line no new taxes and no
negative impact on inflationary
pressures thank you Steve Brian
it can have some clarity from me I think
this is fair when we consider as the
government must the whole economy and I
think it is proportionate so I welcome
it would my right of a friend agree that
when it comes to the NHS settlement that
has to be seen alongside the budget
announcement on pensions as well as the
NHS long-term Workforce plan and Willie
undertake to work with all payer review
bodies going forward to get us to a more
ordered place where the Mandate is given
in the Autumn and the response is heard
in the spring budget
I thank my honorable friend for his
question he made some very sensible
points and of course he's absolutely
right on the pension changes that we
announced in the budget which I think
were something that the BMA have been
asking for for a very long time I think
they welcome them and of course just for
clarity I should make clear that Health
and Care workers remain exempt from the
immigration Health surcharge I think he
speaks a lot of wisdom about potential
refinements to the timetable and we will
look at those very carefully
SNP spokesperson Peter Graham thank you
madam Deputy speaker and can I thank the
chief secretary for advanced copy of his
statement it was noticeable that in his
initial statement he didn't mention the
fact that the British economy has been
in standstill since before the pandemic
it was noticeable that neither he nor
his opposite number and labor bench want
to admit the part that brexit has played
in that everybody has been affected by
kovid everybody has been affected by the
war in Ukraine only one state in Europe
is suffering from the self-inflicted
damage of brexit and that is why
economic growth in the European Union is
and will continue to be higher than it
is here
and then well certainly we welcome the
news that the government have finally
decided to honor The Pledge on public
sector pay military secretary
acknowledge that in almost every single
case the pay increases are being offered
to public sector workers will be less
than increasing the cost of living so
it's in real terms it's a cut will they
acknowledge in almost every case the
Scottish government have already settled
with our essential public sector workers
almost every case a substantially higher
pay deal for essential workers in
Scotland and in most cases certainly
throughout our NHS without a single day
being lost through strike action what
did the Scottish government getting
right that this government finds so
difficult
one of the biggest challenges facing the
economy is shortage of workers so what a
brilliant move to address that by
charging essential workers more to come
here and contribute to our economy
can we have full details of the
increases to immigration fees including
a full statement of the respected
economic impact including an indication
as to the impact it's likely to have on
immigration numbers are we going to be
driving away essential workers and
causing more damage to the economy
simply to feed the right-wing fantasies
of the Daily Mail and the Daily Express
and given that there is almost unanimous
agreement in Scotland that we don't need
less immigration we need more isn't it
time that the Scottish Parliament
answerable to the Scottish people was
given the powers to decide on
immigration policies that we need rather
than constantly being dragged down by
the field policies of this United
Kingdom government
does he accept the ramp inflation and
stagnant economic growth are not
essential they are deliberate political
choices of this field government yeah
yeah
Redemption phrase questions look I think
we can uh agree to disagree on some of
that what we've got to what we've got to
understand is that if you look at the
growth levels over the last two years in
the G7 this this economy in this country
has performed well and he makes a number
of points look I think people are
getting very weary of this constant
refrain around brexit there are people
who voted for brexit or people didn't
vote for brexit it's happened we are now
going to take every step we can to
maximize the benefits and the
opportunities and the greater discretion
that we have consequential of that
decision uh with respect to the specific
questions about the Visa fees I'm sure
that my colleagues in the home office
will publish those in due course this is
a carefully calibrated decision it's not
been motivated motivated by political
Dogma but I but a clear decision to take
necessary steps to avoid additional
borrowing but to meet the outcomes and
the numbers that derived from the prbs
which is in itself an evidence-based uh
advice to the government this is a
careful set of judgments and clearly
it's uh not going to please everyone but
we've got to make decisions in the
interest of the Holy economy at this
time
Richard Fuller Madam Deputy speaker it
was revealing that the shadow Chief
secretary couldn't tell the house
whether labor was in favor of the pay
Awards or against it perhaps he's not
sure if labor members are going to be
joining Strikers who are stopping my
constituents receiving health care or
their children getting to school but my
right honorable friend is absolutely
right that constituents have the right
to expect productivity improvements to
match these pancreas can you explain to
the house a bit more about what the next
steps with his productive review will be
yes I can I've written to every spending
minister in the last week I'll be having
conversations with them and The Wider
Representatives about what can be done
differently to drive savings and more
productivity from what money taxpayers
money that we spend across Whitehall but
I'd just like to return to his previous
point I would just draw his attention
and The house's attention to what the
IMF said
for every additional 25 billion of
spending that's 0.5 on inflation so if
Labor's plans to spend an additional 28
billion they might say it might be a bit
later on in the parliament it it might
be an attempt to outwit the government
in terms of the massive leadership that
we've shown on green finance and on the
green economy but it would be
inflationary he needs to come to terms
with that because the British people
will in due course
Daisy Cooper can you open Deputy speaker
wealth creation and health creation are
two sides of the same coin and so it's
hardly surprising that the obr has said
that economic inactivity has increased
as many more people are starting ill
health as the main reason for not
working but when every single part of
our economy farming Hospitality science
engineering are struggling to recruit
the international talent that it needs
why on Earth is this government about to
take this anti-business measure of
increasing the cost of recruiting people
from abroad through an increased Health
surcharge rather than reversing the tax
cuts for the big Banks closing the
loopholes in the windfall tax and
clamping down on tax avoidance as the
liberal Democrats have called for
we've got record levels of migration at
the time the government at this time at
the budget we set out a very clear plan
to get more people in this country back
into workplace with a number of
interventions through DWP and through
the Health Service we have had to make a
fine judgment around those fees in the
context of not borrowing any more money
and it if they if her party wishes to be
taken seriously as a party of government
they'd have to make the numbers add up
from the chief secretary's statement and
would he be kind enough to confirm for
teachers in Kettering that the six and a
half percent pay increase recommended by
the independent pay review body delivers
the biggest pay increase for teachers in
30 years that the new starting salary
for teachers of thirty thousand pounds
will be at its highest ever level and
that the government will be fully
funding the pay award so that schools
don't have to raid their own budgets to
honor it Chief secretary as ever my
honorable friend is spot on everything
he said is absolutely correct this is a
significant pay settlement for teachers
and I I hope that in due course we will
learn that striking workforces will end
their action and we can look forward
with confidence to the Autumn term
John Trickett
I meant
proposes effectively that the pay Rises
which are being offered which are less
than rate of inflation for every single
of the millions of people who work hard
for our Public Services uh will be paid
for effectively by what he calls our
productivity
uh drive now productivity in Tory hands
means cuts to services and reductions in
staff isn't that the case isn't that the
case and let me just make one final
point which is this why did the obr say
this morning that on its present track
we're going to finish up with a debt 300
higher than our GDP when he talks about
sound mini money it simply isn't true is
it
I don't accept his characterization of
the long-term fiscal risk of the economy
what I do accept is that we need to take
tough decisions it seems to me what he's
saying is what I think a significant
charge of his party still believes that
you can borrow borrow borrow and in due
course if you ever get into government
or raise taxes sequentially as happened
previously yeah Bob Blackman
thank you
my right on Friends statement today and
given that almost every single one of
the public sector union leaders has
called for the government to accept the
pay review offer does he agree with me
they should immediately see Soul strike
action get back to work and provide the
service that the public need
I absolutely agree with my honorable
friend and that is indeed what we expect
to see in the coming days this is a
tough uh decision based on evidence but
based on what's right for the economy
and the public sector as a whole and I
hope that that is what happens in the
coming hours and days
uh Gavin Newlands the truth is the UK is
in real trouble and it's all
constituents through Sky High mortgage
rates and food places that are paying
the police are public financials are
more exposed to Rising inflation than
any other comparable country the UK has
borrowed twice the inflation linked
burdens of any other any other
government where their government pays
to borrow uh has risen by two percent
compared to the G7 average of a half a
percent the obr says the UK government
debt is forecast arise by 3.1 percent of
GDP this year compared with average
Falls of 1.8 in other European countries
so will it come clean with the house and
they do their constituents about just
how close has government have driven us
to the economic precipice
accept virtually anything he said uh
what I what I do accept is that the
whole of the world is dealing with
massive inflationary pressures and if
you look across the continent of the of
Europe you will see very very similar
figures of course they differ in some
respects but what we can say is that
this government is determined to bring
inflation down and today's decisions are
another contribution on that journey to
Harvard inflation this year
which is both fair to them but crucially
to the taxpayer as well is Minister able
to update the house on what steps he
will be taking to eliminate public
sector waste to ensure that these
settlements are sustainable for the
taxpayer
well I think the first step today has
been to ensure that we weren't going to
borrow any more to make this second
work and the productivity review that
will be going on in the coming days and
weeks leading up to the Autumn statement
will be a key element of that I've not
wanted to set a target for that because
I will be looking everywhere to find
better ways of spending taxpayers money
to ensure that we deliver the services
and the commitments we set out the
spending review but also in the most
efficient and effective way
uh in men's very grateful Madam Deputy
speaker
um Deputy speaker I'm a little concerned
at the 1.425
billion pounds
um which is to be found from within the
department of education's existing
budget between now and 2025 uh 525
million in this financial year and a
further 900 million in the next
financial year and can the minister be a
bit more specific exactly where that's
being taken from within the within the
department for education's Budget in
order to meet the teachers pay increase
and while of course we welcome the fact
that the government is honoring the
teacher a bit peer review body
um recommendations let's not forget that
the the envelope for the review bodies
is set by the government in the first
first place and there is of course
something what else that's going on in
this particular situation and that is we
do currently have a recruitment and
retention crisis amongst our teaching
Workforce with something like 20 of
newly qualified teachers leaving after
three years and 40 leaving after five
years nobody goes into teaching because
of the money but it always helps and a
rise in language inflation would
certainly help
well I thank your gentleman for his uh
question I I think he he welcomes what
we've decided to do with the six and a
half percent uh pay increase which
leaves a typical teacher with 44 300
pounds we are re-prioritizing within the
department of education's existing
budget to deliver the additional funding
to schools but we're protecting the
course of schools funding and Frontline
Services we've put additional sums of
money through the spending review and
subsequent uh fiscal events 330 million
in 23 24 550 million in 24 25 the
numbers add up and he will recognize
that
police Cameron
okay thanks Madam Deputy speaker I
recently joined the PCS Union in East
Coast rights Center one tax office for
their campaign on Fair pay and many tell
me they are struggling on minimum wages
so the situation is that we have very
dedicated public servants who are
struggling now in cost of living to make
ends meet so does he sure may concern
that much more must be done to secure a
fair deal that is acceptable to those
who are working on the front line
well I think I'd say to the The
Honorable lady very respectfully that
you know we've taken a number of
interventions and made a number of
decisions here across the board and that
doesn't just mean a single percentage as
I said that in some detail across
different workforces what those
percentages were and sometimes those
distributions within education are
designed to uplift more of those at the
lower levels I'm happy to correspond
with her on anything specifically she
wants to bring my attention to within
obviously the uh Devolution framework
Margaret Ferrier Deputy speaker and I
thank the chief secretary for his
statement the average time that it takes
for a first-time buyer to save for a
deposit has has claimed to a record high
of 10 years often meaning that only the
most privileged in society can afford to
get a fruit in the housing ladder with
wages stagnating and high ranks
hindering saving what steps are the
government taking to support individuals
wishing to purchase the first property
government has a extensive program led
by the Secretary of State uh for for uh
D luck and I'm sure he'd be very happy
to set out the further work he's doing
in advance of the Autumn statement